l'histoire de john glenn qui a 77 ans
retourne dans l'espace nous a donné
envie de nous intéresser à ce que l'on
nomme aujourd'hui les seniors en france
8 millions de personnes sont âgées de
plus de 65 ans des retraités de plus en
plus occupés n'ayant parfois pas une
seconde pour souffler alain doublé ce
qui est vincent bouffartigue ont suivi
un groupe de retraités en vacances dans
un village des hautes-alpes ambiance et
bonne humeur assurée hautes-alpes au
dessus du lac de serre ponçon
ces randonneurs ont tous plus de 70 ans
sans aucun entraînement il se lance dans
l'apprentissage de l' escalade
il n'est jamais trop tard pour bien
faire quelles sont vos impressions vous
recommencerez ah oui
dans ce site magnifique un village de
vacances réservé aux retraités du
bâtiment des hommes et des femmes ont
décidé de profiter à fond de l'entente
libre que j'ai fait la conquête d'une
petite espagnole est je voudrais parler
c'est rigolo véritable deux seigneurs
sur trois partant en vacances chaque
année ils n'étaient que 1 sur 2 en 1981
né dans les années 30 les retraités
d'aujourd'hui ont connu les trente
glorieuses et l'avènement du tourisme
alors sans complexe et pensionnaires
profite de toutes les activités
quinze minutes de repos en période de
vacances scolaires mamies et papys
récupèrent leurs petits-enfants emmené
avec eux une activité supplémentaire
bain pendant quelques instants
ils se retrouvent dans la même salle
pour dîner mais très vite chacun
reprendra ses occupations
la soirée va pouvoir commencer
ils sont là pour s'amuser pour faire
provision de souvenirs pour lier
connaissance
ça c'est des relations que c'est un bon
dans toutes les années alors on fait
connaissance il ya des affinités
finalement est ce que vous voyez qu'on
donnait là donc on en est non parce que
il ya des poteaux de toulouse m il ya
des marseillais alors voyons un peu ce
qu'il fallait se déplacer ses couteaux
écrit alors savoir des cartes postales
est ce que c'est important de se faire
belle le soir oui on voit même et pour
les autres vous avez réussi une soirée
casino a été organisé spécialement pour
eux et si on joue pour rire mais ils
savent qu'ils sont privilégiés plus
riche que ne l'étaient leurs parents
mais aussi généralement en meilleure
santé mais on s'amuse bien on ne s'amuse
surtout pas hier on a bien rigolé
quelques heures plus tard c'est encore
eux sur la piste de danse allez allez
allez ce n'était pas la peine de le
répéter c'est ce qu'on appelle les
retraités du troisième type
notre invité est dany